what could that shot do to a person that
either go straight through or a to
bounce around on the inside of you it
could go through someone and through
someone else Wow okay the massacre at
Orlando's pulse nightclub is the third
mass shooting in six months and the
deadliest in recent US history and like
most other mass shootings since 2009 the
shooter bought his guns legally
it's still legal for people on the
terror watch list to buy guns last year
54 senators who receive funding from the
NRA blocked an effort to change that
Orlando's tragedy has reignited the
fight for the law of war in Kaunas
enough enough enough
of the 25 mass shooting since 2009 we
know that ten of the gunmen bought their
firearms legally some despite having
mental health issues we located ten
shops that sell guns within a 12 mile
radius of the pulse nightclub we were
turned away from five shops and asked to
leave two parking lots
Frank Casanova was one of the few gun
owners who talked he's a veteran who
served in Desert Storm
he has six guns and two kids and he's
always packing heat it's up to me to
protect myself and my family it's nobody
else's really if more people in pulse
nightclub were armed what do you think
would have happened I think instead of
50 he could have got three or five or
ten but I don't think he would he got 50
I think they would have it would have
been able to protect themselves a little
bit you know it wouldn't have been a
huge bloodbath or more casuals no we
found a shooting range that led us
inside but asked to not be identified I
wanted to try to understand why people
love guns even after the horror that
just occurred miles away select you it
Bart
select far flip that safety switch it
out of one I did that okay I feel like I
have a lot of power in my hands right
now that I don't want the rifle used by
the shooter in Orlando was a Sig Sauer
mcx which is similar to the ar-15 I was
shooting in that it's portable
customizable and accurate in other words
the ar-15 is the weapon of choice for
massacre
it's been used in at least three recent
mass shootings people like it because
the Army American
sales of the ar-15 spiked after the
Sandy Hook elementary school shooting in
2012 because people feared there might
be new restrictions on it but nothing
changed even though a majority of
Americans are in support of stricter gun
laws you ready okay and that means these
weapons many of which were originally
intended for the battlefield remain
pretty easy to get that's something I
couldn't get out of my head
so long as the status quo remains we're
only gonna see more tragedies that was a
lot more loud and forceful than I
expected and and as you can see I'm kind
of shaking right now so personally
enough for me I can say having done this
for the first time and I think I'm also
seeing it in the lens of what just
happened and for that reason I want
nothing to do with rifles for any sort
of fire on